This is a Wendover Productions video in collaboration
with Real Life Lore and made possible by Lootcrate.
Is the European Union a country?
It’s a bit of strange question, with an
easy answer but a difficult explanation.
The answer is no.
The European Union is not a country, but…
you can move between countries without passing
through border control, work between countries
without a Visa, and they use the same currency,
and there are elections to a single parliament,
and there’s a single government, and there
are official languages, and a single economic
market, a single aviation market, and… this
is beginning to sound awfully like… a country.
Let’s do a 90 second recap of how the EU
works.
This is the European Union.
There are 28 member states including the UK
which has voted to leave the EU, but just
hasn’t yet gone through the process to leave.
Of those, these are in the Schengen Zone meaning
that there are no border controls between
them.
That means that a typical border crossing
in the EU looks like this.
These four are legally obliged to be in the
Schengen Zone but just aren’t, and these
two have opt-outs in their treaties that exempt
them from being in the Schengen Zone.
These countries are part of the Eurozone meaning
the euro is their sole legal currency.
These guys are obliged to join the Eurozone
once they reach a certain economic target,
which they haven’t, and these two have opt-outs
exempting them from the Eurozone.
Each member country of the European Union
elects its own Members of the European Parliament,
known as MEPs, but the Parliament can’t
make laws by itself.
Laws are proposed by the European Commission,
who kinda work like an executive branch.
They then go to the Parliament who, if they
approve it, send it to the council of the
European Union.
While the Parliament represents the people
of the European Union since the MEPs are elected
by direct election, the Council represents
the Governments since its made up of a rotating
roster of national ministers.
If a proposed piece of legislation makes it
through both the Parliament and Council of
Europe, it becomes law.
So that’s how the European Union works,
at least a massively simplified version, but
how do countries work… or rather, what makes
a country a country.
Well calling a country a country is a bit
misleading because the word “country”
can mean a lot of things.
What you’re probably thinking of when I
say country is sovereign states—France,
Japan, the US, etc—but there are non-sovereign
states that are countries.
Scotland is a country, indisputably, but it’s
not a sovereign state.
It’s a part of the Sovereign State of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland.
So, once again, what makes a country a country?
Well, there’s something called the Declaratory
Theory of Statehood that sets out four criteria
for statehood.
The first is “a permanent population”—a
country is not a country without people so
it needs people in its territory permanently.
The EU easily has this.
More than half a billion people live within
its borders.
If it were a country, it would be the third
most populous on earth and have one of the
second highest gdps in the world.
The second requirement is a defined territory.
It’s a common misconception that a new country
can only form on unclaimed territory—according
to the declaratory theory a sovereign state
can be created in an area where another sovereign
state already exists.
Just look at North and South Korea—both
claim the territory of each other and yet
they’re both sovereign states.
The European Union has a territory, but its
a bit fuzzy.
Any territory that you can call EU territory
is also territory of other entities, the countries
that make up the EU.
But that doesn’t necessarily stop the EU
from having a territory.
Going back to the example of the UK, the official
sovereign state—the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland—really doesn’t
have any of its own territory.
Any territory of the UK is part of England,
Wales, Scotland, or Northern Ireland—each
countries by themselves.
The US is in a similar situation.
States act kinda-like mini-countries and there
really is no federal territory that is not
part of a state’s territory.
Especially given its open border policy, the
EU’s territory is in function indistinguishable
from that of any sovereign state.
The third requirement is a government and
the government can’t just be a puppet of
another sovereign state.
The government needs to have whats called
“an essential core of independence.”
As I’ve mentioned, the EU has a government
but for a few reasons the EU government is
different from that a sovereign state.
Here’s the problem, the EU’s government
is not independent.
The power comes from below, as in the power
comes from the member states.
The power of most sovereign states also comes
from below, but in that case its the people
that give a state power.
In the case of the EU, since power is granted
by sovereign states, those states are really
above the EU in power and therefore the EU
government is a subservient government.
That violates the criteria for a truly independent
government.
Although, what’s the difference between
this and UK government then—the country
of countries?
The United Kingdom is also made up of countries
so isn’t their government subservient?
Well, in the EU, there is a system and structure
to leaving, whereas in the United Kingdom
or really any other country, the entities
within the sovereign states cannot leave without
a change in government structure and procedure.
When parts of sovereign states leave sovereign
states, they do so typically without a legal
right but rather a moral right.
It’s called “the Right to Revolution”
according to the philosopher John Locke.
When a government no longer serves the people,
as in it fails to protect the rights of the
people or becomes the entity that people need
protection from, there is a near universal
moral understanding that the people can either
overthrow or leave that government.
Members of the EU can choose whether or not
to continue membership on a legal basis rather
than a moral one.
The whole structure and system was set up
by the member states, so even though it is
overseeing the states, the power originates
from the states it oversees.
The continued existence of the EU relies on
the will of its members to continue the system.
That is never the case with an independent
government.
That being said, while the origin of power
may be different, the EU government functions
in most ways like any other government.
It has different branches, agencies, economic
systems, leaders, and more, so while its different,
the EU does partially fulfill the government
requirement for statehood.
The last criteria for statehood outlined in
the Declaratory Theory is “the capacity
to enter into relations with other states”
and the EU absolutely has this.
There are ambassadors to the EU, ambassadors
of the EU, embassies of the EU, embassies
to the EU, intergovernmental organizations
between the EU and non-EU countries, treaties
between the EU and non-EU countries, and more.
While most foreign relations are handled by
individual member countries, there are absolutely
foreign relations of the EU as a whole.
So, the European Union has fulfilled each
criteria for sovereign statehood on out list,
but it still isn’t a state.
Here’s the problem: statehood, as in being
a sovereign country, is not a natural phenomenon.
No part of nature creates countries.
You can call salt salt if it’s made of Sodium
Chloride.
That’s the requirement for salt being salt
and we can’t change that.
That how nature makes salt.
We created the idea of countries.
They’re a social construct, so society decides
what is a sovereign country and what is not.
While we can lay down a number of requisites
for statehood, they are just guidelines to
achieve the final goal—society’s acceptance
of a country.
We can’t just say these criteria make a
country a country unless individuals believe
in those criteria since countries, like all
social constructs, only work if there’s
a collective belief and following of that
system.
It’s similar to money.
Money only works if everyone believes that
pieces of paper equal value.
Countries only work if everyone believes that
certain imaginary lines separate who and what
leads people.
In the case of statehood, you can’t just
ask every person in society whether or not
they think a country is a sovereign country.
There are socially accepted countries already
and therefore those act as a proxy for society
to decide whether a country is sovereign or
not.
A countries sovereignty is judged off of how
many other sovereign countries recognize its
sovereignty.
The European Union is not a sovereign state
because nobody accepts it as one.
While it may function in many ways like a
sovereign country, it is not one because sovereignty
is neither its goal or desire.
This shows you just how difficult it is to
define what a country is.
Supranational organizations like the EU act
like countries, but at the same time… so
do some subnational entities—as in parts
of countries.
Most specifically in the US.
(Joseph’s part) States have a level of sovereignty
that blur the line between what is part of
a sovereign country and a county itself.
What is the difference between a state in
the United States and a country.
They fulfill almost all the criteria that
you just heard about so that’s why I asked
the question in collaboration with Wendover
Productions “Is the United States a Country”
over on my channel Real Life Lore.
Please do be sure to check that out, it’s
a great video from a great channel.
A lot of you ask how you can support the channel
and I have a great, fun way courtesy of Lootcrate.
Lootcrate is a monthly mystery crate that
brings collectibles, apparel, tech gadgets,
art, and other gear right to your door.
They have a bunch of different themes to suit
what you like, and if you sign up using the
link trylootcrate.com/wendover you’ll support
the channel so I can keep doing better and
better videos.
On top of that, if you use that link, you
can take 10% off by using the coupon code
bridge10.
These boxes are a fantastic deal.
Each has more than $45 worth of gear for as
low as $11.95 a month plus shipping.
Thats the cost of about four cups of coffee.
It’s a great gift for Christmas, or a great
way to reward yourself.
Once again, if you sign up using the link
trylootcrate.com/wendover and the code bridge10,
you’ll get 10% and help support Wendover
Productions.
Other than that, you can also help this channel
by contributing on Patreon where 100% of the
funds go right back into the channel.
I even release expense reports at the end
of each month.
You can also get great rewards over there
like early access to videos, stickers, hand-written
letters, and most recently, t-shirts.
You can also order a t-shirt by itself for
only $20 through DFTBA.
The link is here and also in the description.
Other than that, please make sure to follow
me on Twitter @WendoverPro, watch my last
video on Every Country in the World here,
check out my fan-moderated subreddit here,
and most of all, subscribe to this channel
to receive all my future videos right when
they come out.
Lastly, this is the final Wendover Productions
video of 2016 and I want to sincerely than
every one of you for your amazing support.
I started this year with about 3,000 subscribers
and now I’m almost at 300,000.
It’s been an awesome year all thanks to
you guys.
Happy Holidays, and I’ll see you in 2017
for the best year of videos you’ve ever
seen.